who were you in high school in 10th
Grade I'm actually curious oh gosh that
is a totally different Candace I mean I
would say I was probably who everybody
was in in 10th Grade you know I was
definitely just trying to figure out who
I was I was skipping classes I was
always in good classes though but I was
skipping them I had a boyfriend who I
was obsessed with you know and so we
were always skipping and going other
places
um definitely not conservative but I
would say not politically inclined at
all which is important to State because
people have kind of shifted The
Narrative and said I was like a radical
leftist or something I just didn't care
about politics never voted
um wasn't following it at all but uh
yeah always loved communication uh
excelled at English and writing and
things of that nature and yeah I mean
teachers would probably say I was a bit
of a smart ass I'd be surprised if you
said that no way they called You Smarter
I was always consistently a smartass I
can see it Candace absolutely yeah what
do you think your your fellow classmates
are saying about you know I can't I
didn't see this comment or I totally saw
it coming totally I would think they
would say the opposite yeah and my my
parents I mean just I've always been
very sure of myself even when I was
wrong do you know what I mean is that
that makes sense like I have a
two-year-old
I have a two-year-old toddler son who's
got that same characteristic where he's
always very sure of himself even when
he's completely wrong so for you to a
4.5 GPA we need a 4.2 GPA oh I was like
of the 3.5 okay because I just didn't
care got it and that was 3.5 without
trying at all were you playing sports
were you an athlete cheerleader
cheerleader okay big high school or
small High School uh 2 000 people
graduated in high school so relatively
big more English less math did you like
science hated Math and Science okay
loved English communication so kind of
makes sense and I'm doing a notification
um and when I graduated I majored in
journalism in English so words always
just came very easily to me I loved to
read which was uh my dweeb habit that I
had developed from the time I could pick
up a book what'd you read back then what
were you reading I was actually reading
all fiction my mom was a part of some
weird book club where she'd just get
like Nora Roberts and Dean Koontz sort
you know and it was just what I was
reading obviously the books were bigger
than my head when I was younger but it
was just what was on our bookshelf so uh
I read through everything my mom read
through I was very into Harry Potter
forget it like a racing home to try to
yeah to try to beat my mom to read the
books when they came out like very into
the Wizarding worlds of Harry Potter
have you ever met him I haven't met him
yet
yet I like that meaning like you plan I
plan to meet Harry Potter nice yeah
maybe we can arrange something yes
Hogwarts action
what house would you be in did you guys
read Harry Potter no that is deeply
upsetting to me every person should
actually read it
it's a really she's a really good book I
mean it's not didn't become this whole
thing as it was a bad book I'm telling
you it's really good what house are you
I but you know what I don't wow
yeah
I feel like I would be like hairy like
it would be like between Gryffindor and
Slytherin and then I would be able to
pick my house that's a reference you
that watched Harry Potter yeah anything
that she's talking about but people that
are watching this show do because Harry
Potter was Sensational and they should
place you in a house I want to actually
know yeah Rob can you ask them what
house they would put him in
very important
they're gonna guess what'd you guys
think uh Gryffindor or Slytherin they're
gonna say Pat there's more no there's
more houses they could be but I'm saying
they're gonna pick out of those two main
ones he has to be Gryffindor now I have
to go
it could be Ravenclaw oh Ravenclaw no
you're just blowing his mind yeah
Rob why don't you uh first of all why
don't you do this do a poll to see what
percentage of the audience has read the
books if we can kind of get an idea red
or watch the movie I think it's both
counts both counts okay
yeah yeah there's good people in there
so Ken is in in your you know High
School Pat asked like you know you're
getting old you're getting older at what
moment was the political thing hit in
your head like that woman where you're
like I gotta kind of get involved
recently I mean I I guess it's not that
recently anymore but not until Trump
came down the escalator in 2015. and I
think it's because it was Donald Trump
he made everybody even if you weren't
politically inclined you suddenly had an
opinion yeah for sure couldn't look away
yeah so I didn't have there was no
political inclinations in my house my
parents were not politically engaged my
grandparents I who I grew up for a good
portion of my childhood in their home
weren't politically engaged so I would
say I came from a very apolitical family
but of course left-leaning because
you're black and you're supposed to be a
Democrat so that's just kind of the
cultural poisoning that goes on and um
in 2015 trumping on the escalator I
remember thinking like I don't want this
guy to win because not because of any
reason other than he's an Entertainer
you know exactly so to me it was it was
like if someone like Hulk Hogan was
running I would just be like I don't
understand you know it didn't feel
appropriate after Obama was in office
and then I watched a speech that he gave
in Dimondale Michigan and he made this
very interesting elevator pitch to Black
America and he was kind of just listing
through all of the actual factual
statistics in Black America of like this
is the poverty rate this is whatever it
is and at the end he's just like I mean
did you try something different what do
you have to lose I was like a pretty
good business pitch like saying like I'm
the greatest person everybody's saying
look around you you've been doing the
same thing Democrats 50 years nothing's
gotten better why don't you just try
something different and after I finished
watching it I like remember turning on
whatever I was normally used to watching
MSN CNN and they completely pretended
that he attacked black Americans called
him a racist and he gave the most racist
speech said black Americans were all
living in poverty and it was just such a
blatant lie that I was confused about
why my trusted sources were lying got
you and then I kind of started wondering
what the racist side was saying and I
just got curious so we were just talking
about about high school you left High
School you graduated high school and you
went Rhode Island not exactly a Bastion
of conservatism no it's not and then
from there you went to work for Vogue
magazine which was even further left
than the University of Rhode Island so
where were you like on political
spectrum and just thinking maybe if you
didn't think of it was political but
where was your thought like when you
left
high school then to Rhode Island and
where did you come to where you are
today well I was I was liberal but I
wasn't crazy liberal like you're never
going to find any old pics of I had
Republican friends that you know it was
just a different time I think we were
allowed to kind of be like oh like I'm
left leaning and right leaning and you
could it was okay back then that was
okay back then that was totally fine no
nobody actually really cared it was
college and I would say I was liberal in
the sense that if you had just asked me
generally speaking about things like is
feminism good yes just everything just a
checklist of I had a public school
education you know and I had a public
education so I would have said yes to
this yes to that gay gay rights all of
these things but not forcefully like
there's no old images of Candace like
wearing a hat or marching yeah it
just doesn't exist I just didn't care
very disappointing more of an answer
than I was what about Obama did you vote
for Obama this no straight up no no so
it's so funny is everyone says that
there because I just didn't care I mean
I was no I shouldn't say that I didn't
care I was so happy when Obama won yeah
because he was black because he was
black or because I mean very simple both
reasons because he's black and because
he's very much flaming
um you're saying Obama wears a hat
I have to go to sleep everywhere sure I
think it's wonderful and for those
reasons I remember sitting in my room on
my college campus and like crying then I
Obama like oh yeah this means America's
moving forward tears of joy cheers tears
of joy and I you mean you couldn't not
feel the Obama oh my God it was kinetic
yes we can yeah
how old are you at the time 15 years ago
you were how old you're in college bro I
was in college I remember being my I
think it was my sophomore year about 20
years old so eight so 2008 he's becoming
president you're cannot believe this is
taking place and in the evolution and to
really get into politics doesn't happen
until 2016. yeah yeah and then boom yeah
I went and worked in New York I was
working at a private Equity Firm I was
just like fully trying to get myself out
of student loan debt so it was all about
working for me I was never an idiot I
was always about wanting to get my
finances right I've never not had a job
since I was 14 years old
um my grandfather was very much
impressed upon the Owens you have a job
you work and so for me I just wanted to
get my financial life in order and
coming out of college I had 150k in
student loan debts no money from my
family so it was the pressure to make
money was what my focus was I didn't
really care about
um politics at all 150k where'd you go
to school Rhode Island URI can you
believe that 35k a year and then of
course obviously for a random public
Sallie Mae yeah yeah there's like 37 000
per year so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]